Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Agents of SHIELD Epsiode
5 video.
All about Simmons' odyssey, her time on that
foreign planet.
We still don't know where it is.
I'm thinking less and less that it might be
the Thor versin of Hel.
H-E-L Hel.
But there is a very important reason they
spent so much time filming on that planet
that we can talk about in spoilers, so just
careful if you haven't seen the episode yet
is he going starting off with Simmons initial
time on the planet just like WTF how did I
get here what the hell is going on she's got
the phone and she's able to spend almost as
much time as humans can go without food or
water before she has to move on she has to
go find a source of water which she does to
her great relief so it's kind like the Lawrence
of Arabia on another planet and I just say
that because she's British wooden she loved
to have a TARDIS now she's on the blue planet
where's the blue box she did find the bad
man I'm I'm sure all the pieces there we can
we can put that together but is just the beginning
a series of challenges that Simmons has to
overcome in order to survive if your big fan
of the Odyssey this is like a great allegory
for that story she finds water she defeats
intelligent plant eats said plant and as a
result later in the episode the planet isn't
completely dead there used to be life on it
there's this fungus is other sources of food
on the number for the Simmons versus crazy
pants mystery person she gets captured and
thrown into prison so we know that there are
other people on the planet and she was running
from something the last time we saw her on
the planet so so we know something was chasing
her we found out it was the monster so to
speak I guess we just call the monster for
now but is probably another in human but the
reveal is a citizen of the person and he speaks
English so eventually she finds out that it's
a NASA astronaut that in 2001 went through
the monolith on the orders of NASA that it
was like a NASA manned mission to learn more
about the other planet we can blame the Bush
administration for green lighting that but
he explains some of the rules of the planet
the Simmons is a terrible place she learns
about the no-fly zone she learns about the
nameless danger that will take over her mind
if she's not careful will is kind like this
Robinson Crusoe character you know he has
the skill to survive using completely crazy
but he is definitely a little bit nutters
pretty much given up on being rescued maybe
this is your new home in in court Simmons
is only been there for all losses like screws
planet this blows about how speaking of which
on a number three meet crazy pants will probably
not a bad character but also someone we know
is been holding back information so we can
trust him hundred percent now right now will
just seems like a character device to help
develop Simmons character I don't know if
he's going to turn into something bigger she
wouldn't go back to rescue him if he wasn't
so I'd I do think he's joining the cast somewhat
at least for the first half of the season
but he might be like a snack for the narrative
to eat at a later date record is going to
take you over away here in the EU later something
in humans income destroy you the way well
explains that especially the danger zone is
that people are being sacrificed to this mystery
alien here we know is humanoid in its powers
affect the weather on the planet and it may
or may not be responsible for the once fertile
planet turning into this is Baron rock of
nothingness so on my number two WTF moment
mystery in human alien here very powerful
probably not as evil as we think it is the
whole set it just feels way too obvious for
me like this thing is completely dangerous
it will completely mess with your mind don't
go near it don't learn anything about it using
the twists and situations like that it went
when a character says that someone is super
dangerous they end up being just misunderstood
they're not dangerous at all if Simmons was
able to use the stars to find a way to get
back on to figure out the location and the
timing of the portals she can definitely learn
what this thing is but I don't think that
it's the last I think that it's something
that's also trapped on this planet I know
I talked about the idea that Andrew might
be lashed but wouldn't it be cool to if flash
were some some other character and he were
tied to this phenomenon this other in human
on this planet and he was trying to get rid
of in humans so that they would turn into
this crazy in humans to destroy this planet
of course we don't know that he actually destroy
the planet we just know that will thinks that
he did finally on my number one WTF moment
Simmons after escaping the planet convinces
Fitz to help her rescue will that in credit
seem went when the sun comes up was just meant
to be this looks a stark contrast to just
the show that will was in a hallucination
he's an actual character that was the thing
that he missed most about the earth that reminds
about Simmons so he's hitting like an all
time low the real question noses when they
go back to rescue him will that other alien
come back through the portal with them somehow
I've I feel like they wouldn't tease this
mystery powerful character without allowing
him to come into our world at some point in
the only way to do that is through this portals
for still no closer to finding out that planet
is but now that we know we can go back and
forth a little bit easier the pry figured
out that a pry be Simmons and Fitz's are figuring
out what's going on with this mystery planet
in this mystery figure here this mystery in
human just remember that he and Lasch are
two different characters but they might be
connected there might be there might be some
mystery connection that we don't know about
yet let me know though what was your favorite
moment in this episode Woody think about them
devoting an entire episode justice Simmons
arc I feel like it was good pay off like for
for her time during the break it all the time
we didn't see her for really like there weren't
that many Easter eggs in the episode like
it wasn't very marveled he was really just
like a normal sci-fi story there weren't that
many identifiable comic book moments other
than the fact that they're facing an in human
here that they don't know anything about I'm
totally cool with the show doing stuff like
this there been a couple really good Simmons
episode it's kind like that episode in season
two were it showed her being part of Hydra
she was supposed to infiltrate Hydra and pretend
like she was one of their lab techs so this
is kind like an even bigger version of that
is a solo Simmons story great character work
she can be one of the more interesting characters
when the giver good stories and I feel like
last year when they started to push and in
humans she got a little bit racist but she
got very xenophobic about the in humans so
I feel like this is a nice twist on that I
did see a little confusion about the sexiness
of the people wondering if Simmons is like
break pregnant with some some baby no no I
don't think that she's pregnant I think that
there their relationship on that of the planet
would just meant to be like a touching moment
in time so when he comes back naturally is
gonna complicate the love triangle they have
going on with Fitz but I don't think it's
going to be that big of a thing that is that
the show that Simmons and this other human
bonded in their isolation is trying to provide
each other with some comfort dividends like
a one-off think that I can move in together
anything whenever he comes back but next week
looks like it's going to be a good may episode
hopefully will find out what's going on with
Andrew because he is mostly tied to her storylines
again there number of possibilities I definitely
don't think that he is dead otherwise Junior
von struck are wouldn't be crapping his pants
right here I think that either he is an in
human himself and manifested powers and saved
himself or another in humans swooped in and
help them out or he could be like Coulson
is be a normal bad ass on zone if you member
one of the earliest marble short films they
ever did like way back in phase 1 was Coulson
in the convenience store taking the ship out
of that robber just in being bad as it was
the funniest thing ever this that when they
film that they actually it was so short you
know wasn't supposed to be this big deal they
were supposed to spend a lot of money but
they did such a big affect sequence with the
big fight scene with all the way the camera
spun around that they blew their budget so
when they got to the next short films they
did it was just Coulson and Sitwell sitting
in that diner talking to each other like we
can't spend any money on this we blew the
budget on the last one as far as a note the
last short film that marble did was the health
of the King one fireman three the one with
with the 10 rings in the Mandarin the real
Mandarin so be sure to subscribe to get next
week's video was can happen tonight is there's
an episode of arrow are trying to catch up
with Supergirl which I think is going to be
an interesting show this season I haven't
seen anything besides the first episode in
an pilots tend to be a little bit weird compared
to the rest of the series they were they were
a film several episodes they've got a bunch
a comic book characters I'm most interested
to learn about Maxwell Lord on the show there
been versions of him in the past but I think
the CBS version this Supergirl version is
going to be the most powerful I also say Captain
America Civil War trailer the latest Intel
is that it's gonna drop in December near Star
Wars the force awakens of course this is going
to use its biggest film to promote its other
biggest film the White has weight for all
that stuff to post you can click here for
all my Captain America Civil War videos and
you can click here for the flash from last
night thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight